[Musica]
questo è il pianeta terra
conosciamo tutti questo è il pianeta
come dire più complesso non diciamo più
bello della galassia sicuramente ce ne
sono altri ma questo è il più complesso
che noi conosciamo il funzionamento di
questo pianeta dipende
da fattori da un intreccio di fattori
molto mostra complessi tante tante
componenti la biosfera la criosfera gli
oceani e soprattutto l'atmosfera
atmosfera e quello strato sottile come
l'ho chiamato amstrong che in un certo
senso mette insieme tutto il sistema fa
comunicare tutte le componenti fra di
loro ma proprio perché così sottile e
anche il più vulnerabile e quello che
stiamo toccando di più in questo momento
ma la cosa importante è che si è toccata
e una di queste componenti
ghiacci più tra storie l'atmosfera
modificate tutto il sistema
allora per almeno gli ultimi tre
miliardi di anni da quando iniziata
diciamole raffredda chiamiamola così
della nostra terra
il clima si è voluto con questo
alternarsi molto regolare di periodi
glaciali e periodi interglaciali noi
siamo alla fine di un periodo
interglaciale caldo relativamente caldo
l'ultimo periodo lasciare è stato 20.000
anni fa
pensate a questo alternarsi come a una
pulsazione regolare determinata dall
equilibrio di tutte queste componenti e
poi all'improvviso
esce fuori questa specie a specie umana
che a cominciare da circa duecento anni
fa comincia a modificare questo sistema
in tantissimi modi
l'inquinamento di aria acqua
deforestazione dissesto idrogeologico
chi più ne ha più ne metta
e poi i cambiamenti climatici
noi chiamiamo questa era questi ultimi
200 anni
l'antropocene perché perché oggi
l'essere umano una parte fondamentale di
questo sistema
la prima volta che io
sono stato esposto antropocene in queste
in queste
slide e chiedere che cosa c'entrano le
esplosioni nucleari lo screen allora
negli anni 80 di averlo parecchie più
giovane uno studente degli stati uniti
stanno lavorando migliorato il tema del
mio dottorato era l'inverno nucleare
una teoria la posta da un famoso chimico
paul crutzen
diceva che se ci fosse una fosse stata
una grande piano della guerra fredda se
ci fosse stata una guerra nucleare
sarebbero stati incendi di proporzioni
bibliche che avrebbero immesso quantità
tali di fuliggine atmosfera da schermare
la luce del sole e quindi gettare la
superficie della terra sarebbe rimasto
in questo perenne freddo inverno
noi fummo i primi in questo laboratorio
ammettere guerre nucleari nei modelli
climatici potrebbe pensare insomma 27
anni per me era una cosa abbastanza
abbastanza particolare poi la guerra
fredda è finita per fortuna
1989 caduta del muro di berlino il mio
professore bene mi fa
questa teoria ormai non importa più a
nessuno dobbiamo applicare i nostri
mirelli su qualcosa di nuovo e purtroppo
proprio in quegli anni stava venendo
fuori un'altra grandissima minaccia
dell'antropocene quella dei cambiamenti
climatici
si cominciava già a parlare gli anni 80
anni dopo 30 anni di ricerche oggi
sappiamo molto sui cambiamenti climatici
siamo sicuri che il clima si sta
riscaldando circa un grado a livello
globale negli ultimi 120 anni adesso
vedrete sini ma che cos'è un grado in
realtà un grado e tantissimo e gli
ultimi 10.000 anni nell'ultimo un peto
caldo non è mai accaduto
la terra non l'ha mai vista totalmente
in nessuno dei periodi caldi di quella
di quella pulsazione che abbiamo visto e
sappiamo anche che questo è dovuto a noi
alle attività umane
emissioni di gas serra soprattutto neve
carbonica dall'uso di combustibili
fossili metano da allevamenti intensivi
se sappiamo che se continuerà come sta
andando avanti adesso ci potremo
riscaldare ancora i 45 gradi
questo ci dicano i nostri comandi che
serve una cosa che il pianeta non ha mai
visto ma sto qui a spiegare che cosa
significherebbe sincere uno
sconvolgimento completo del sistema
climatico
eventi estremi come quello che sta fuori
di qui sta accadendo un evento estremo
proprio adesso
innalzamento del livello del mare
istruzione zone costiere scioglimento
dei ghiacci e il nostro maggior
serbatoio di acqua potabile
innesco di punti di non ritorno allo
scioglimento del ghiaccio agorà landia
metri di livello termale che sale il
nostro allen carr vedi tutti
significherebbe i vostri figli i nostri
figli i nostri nipoti di avrebbero in
pianeta diverso da quello di oggi è
molto molto meno ospitale in particolare
una delle zone che sarà molto meno
ospitali
da qui alle prossime decadi se la
situazione non cambia il mediterraneo al
mediterraneo una di quelle che noi
chiamiamo la fox fox zone calde del
riscaldamento globale
ci sono alcune zone del globo che sono
più sensibili per diverse ragioni del
nostro a spiegare sui profili 12 minuti
ma una di queste mediterraneo ci
aspettiamo eventi sempre più intensi vi
ricordate la tempesta avaya per chi
insomma dall'altro lato del
dell'italia nella zona est dove vivo
anch'io ha distrutto intere foreste
l'innalzamento del livello del mare
l'inondazione di venezia e soprattutto
il mediterraneo dovrebbe diventare molto
più caldo e molto più secco per quelli
di voi che ricordano l'estate del 2003
30.000 morti 30 miliardi di danni
all'agricoltura non solo non dovrebbe
diventare la normalità per noi ma ce ne
sarebbe di molto peggio ne prendete
l'italia spostare la di mille che loro
sin giù questo il clima che ci aspetta
un clima semi semiarido quindi noi
dobbiamo preoccuparci molto dei
cambiamenti climatici
il fisco le brutte notizie cominciano le
buone sappiamo come risolvere il
problema la cosiddetta green economy
quindi prima di tutto decarbonizzazione
del sistema energetico
economia circolare di uso delle risorse
economia il chilometro zero molto
importante soprattutto per l'italia
riforestazione non risolverebbe il
problema ma contribuirebbe è qualcosa
che si può fare anche a costi contenuti
e stato stimato che più o meno
costerebbe l'uno per mille del pil
globale all'anno il pil globale cresce
del 3 per cento
contenere i danni del riscaldamento
globale all'interno dell'obiettivo di
parigi richiedere e l'uno per mille
quindi praticamente niente
ma quindi voi vi chiederete
ma insomma sappiamo il problema sappiamo
chi è la causa siamo noi sappiamo come
sopra si può risolvere che possiamo
risolverlo noi perché non si fa qualcosa
in più
perché non si riesce la comunità
internazionale a mettere insieme come ha
fatto per i votanti cariche sono andate
questa che io chiamo pandemia ambientale
globale perché non è solo i cambiamenti
climatici è il grande killer
l'inquinamento 9 milioni di persone
all'anno muoiono per l'inquinamento va
bene
ovviamente questo richiederebbe molti
più di 12 minuti però io volevo
così sottolineare quattro punti che
visitano tutto il nostro coraggio
superare dei dogmi il primo è quello che
chiama il dogma del pil della crescita
del pil
noi oggi accendiamo la tv alter giornale
ci dicono va tutto bene perché pil
crescere ma il pil non è un indicatore
di benessere sicuramente non è un
indicatore di benessere collettivo
in una società in cui l'uno per cento
della popolazione detiene il 50 per
cento delle ricchezze in più nel nulla
può crescere sempre senza uccidere il
suo ospite
quindi la nostra economia ha in sé il
germe della sua autodistruzione io spero
che i giovani anche che sono qui che sti
nell'economia possano venire fuori da
una nuova teoria economica
sistema economico che ci possa salvare
ma c'è il dogma dello spreco
oggi noi sprechiamo il 65 per cento
dell'energia prodotta il 30 per cento
dell'acqua il 35 per cento del cibo e
soprattutto sprechiamo tempo stiamo
sprecando il tempo e tutte queste
risorse cibo acqua tempo ne abbiamo poco
non possiamo aspettare e lo stiamo
sprecando e poi il dogma che lo sviluppo
richiede il petrolio questa è una roma
degli anni 60 70 del petrolio ma oggi
questo non è più vero la green economy
oggi dal punto di vista economico e
competitiva con
con l'economia fossile
si fa passare il letto il petrolio è
finita dobbiamo passare alla prossima
generazione di un'era che possiamo
chiamare l'era del sole perché il sole
alla fine ci dà tutta l'energia in varie
forme di cui abbiamo bisogno è il terzo
il quarto dogma è quello che i cambianti
climatiche siano un problema di qualcun
altro
ma l'altra questo non è vero perché
quello in un mondo globalizzato quello
che c'è in australia si ripercorrerà per
tutto lo abbiamo visto con la pandemia
specialmente per noi cambiamenti
climatici sono un nostro problema io
personalmente
anche se sappiamo qual è la soluzione il
mondo sta andando in quella direzione
dobbiamo essere ottimisti
non sono ottimista riguardo queste
negoziazioni internazionali secondo me i
governi non riusciranno mai a
raggiungere degli accordi internazionali
per 30 anni ci hanno provato e non ci
sono riusciti neanche l'accordo di
parigi e un accordo legalmente
vincolante
secondo me la più la spinta può e deve
venire dal basso da noi della società
civile soprattutto dai giovani non solo
dai giochi da tutti perché però giovani
sono quelli che radieranno questo secolo
che erediteranno questo pianeta e quindi
hanno diritto ad avere un secolo ed un
pianeta migliore è importante che in
questo siamo tutti i protagonisti
tutti qui possiamo essere gli eroi
coraggiosi dei fumetti che leggevamo
quando l'età quando eravamo ragazzini
quindi questo è il mio messaggio
fondamentale però volevo chiudere come
un aneddoto
quello che vedete qui è il razzo che
dovrebbe portarci su masper va bene
il fatto di elon musk era un maschio è
un grande visionario lunghi e un
grandissimo rispetto sta facendo delle
cose veramente avveniristiche però una
volta ho sentito una intervista in cui
gli hanno chiesto ma perché dobbiamo
andare su marte
bella domanda
e lui ha detto varie cose esportazione
c'era ma ha detto anche
dobbiamo andare su marte perché se un
giorno la terra diventata invivibile
allora avremo bisogno di un posto dove
andare e questo mi ha lasciato molto
perplesso
noi stiamo andando nella china di quelli
in visibilità e dobbiamo fare è
veramente il coraggio di fermarla ma per
fermarla noi dobbiamo
frantumare l'ultimo dogma il dogma è che
la società umana non sia parte di questo
pianeta
pensiamo di sm fori di poterne
di poterlo sfruttare in tutti i modi
possibili ma questo non è vero siamo
parte di quella postazione e quindi
dobbiamo convivere in sintonia con il
pianeta
quindi la mia risposta era nas che se io
fossi stato lì sarebbe stata
sì sarà anche vero ma questo il pianeta
più bello che abbiamo il più complesso
il più sorprendente ed io non ho nessuna
intenzione di doverlo abbandonare e
spero che voi siete d'accordo con me
grazie
[Musica]